pewnie słyszeliście o strefie czystego
transportu w warszawie
już niedługo
nie będziecie mogli wjechać swoim autem spalinowym
do większości stolicy
a to dlatego że taki pomysł przyjął Rafał trzaskowski
ze swoimi ludźmi
wykonując tym samym założenia ustawy
o elektromobilności z 21. Roku
którą przegłosował pis
natomiast na jaw wychodzą nowe informacje
w 22. Roku miasto warszawa
podpisało umowę
z fundacją promocji pojazdów elektrycznych
w której zobowiązało się
że nie będzie podejmować żadnych czynności
które mogłyby przeszkodzić
w wprowadzeniu strefy czystego transportu
Jak to się wszystko doskonale ze sobą składa
z 1
strony auta spalinowe nie będą mogły wjeżdżać do miasta
ale z 2. miasto ma podpisaną umowę
z fundacją promującą samochody elektryczne
a to wszystko w imię unijnej polityki klimatycznej
która opiera się na zasadach antysamochodzizmu
i którą przyjmuje zarówno pis
Jak i platforma